so you've probably seen the destiny 2
trailer right and if you like me you are
definitely looking forward to this game
release so I've watched the trailer
about 30 times now one because i really
like it but two so really i could look
through it and look at all aspects and
break down a few details clues are a
hidden bits of information that i think
the trailer reveals all so don't worry
if you're new to destiny I'll be sure to
explain each element and in the future
I'm going to break down the whole
storyline and how loot works and things
like that as we approach September the
eighth and destiny to release ok so
let's do this first up let's start with
the returning characters from the first
decima game kids sick is the standout
character and if you don't know him
think of deadpool's attitude mixed with
Boba Fett and the gun-slinging skills of
the man with no name I was magnificent
kid 6 is also joined by other members of
the Vanguard who basically are the elite
guardians who have moved up to
management level these are the viola the
blue chap giving the riveting speech to
his troops and I Cora ray who gave kid a
little feedback that was inspiring I'm
hoping this will be representative of a
character and narrative driven adventure
which if I'm completely honest was
pretty much missing from the first
destiny title each of the Vanguard
represents a character class in the game
kds a hunter I Cora is a warlock and the
varlet it's a Titan which class did you
pick for destiny one and what are you
planning for destiny too I'm a hunter to
the car these three members of the
Vanguard are usually found in the Great
Hall and this is where we meet the Cabal
who are making a return from the
original destiny game but this damn
they've had a few considerable upgrades
these chaps are in fact the red Legion
who will play the main antagonist in
destiny to the typical cabal phalanx now
seem to possess an energy-based shield
or look at the size of this big busted
smashing through the wall with twin
machetes of death the red Legion also
seem to have a new quadrupeds pet just
made to Russia so maybe keep a shotgun
close to hunt but so is the driving
force behind the red Legion scary Gill
Glenn is it I don't know something with
a G go
yeah its goal but we all know we are
only ever going to call him Gary we only
receive a small vignette of the big bad
guy of destiny too but it's enough to
get the juices flowing just in case you
didn't know destiny one and destiny to
our separate games their narrative does
link them together so I'll be sure to
break down that in the future but don't
worry if you're new to destiny you can
jump straight in with destiny to will
destiny one Guardians have an advantage
of a destiny two Guardians well it's
time to break that down because if we
look in the trailer we have just
witnessed all our weapons and pieces of
armor being destroyed as three years of
hard work down the drain this is
cleverly link to the story line because
the red Legion have annihilated our home
three years of memories up in smoke but
of course the positives mean that does
that give destiny wanna miss and those
who are a bit turned off by the poor
reviews now have the chance to come back
to destiny too and we all have an equal
footing speaking of seeing all our
possessions destroyed the entire tower
which has been our home our safe haven
our home base our hangout that's gone to
that's completely up in smoke our home
this ties into a new story line which
will see our Guardian lose everything
and be forced to start again learning to
survive in the wilderness without our
powers will be the core of the story so
you're going to see a lot of things you
won't understand
where could I new hornby I can't wait to
find out if we look at the destinations
in destiny one there is still so many
undiscovered places to find and
investigate we have an entire solar
system our fingertips so pleased destiny
to show me you're in just one ring I'll
do seriously though where would you like
to visit in destiny to going back to the
trailer we see a single guardianship
attempting to fight the kabob I'm hoping
upon hope that this hints at a deeper
impact for the ship's we gather in
destiny want our ships were
ineffectively used as jerk top loading
screens and completely ornamental simply
put this needs to change right this is a
bit of a tangent but did you ever play
the original Tekken on ps1 and I think
we're dresser had this too there was a
mini game similar to galaxian which
allowed us to play whilst the game
loaded I would love this to be part of
destiny too because the Lord times on
the original destiny game were egregious
to say the least maybe the mini game
would give us extra super sore and
expanded I more clip something like that
or maybe it's just wishful thinking I'd
love to know what you think in the
comments so please let me know what on
earth could we use our ships quad some
characters aren't seen in the trailer
and some people believe that these
characters have been killed off such as
the faction leaders who would give us
lovely packages for representing them
where is Amanda Holloway she was
responsible for our ship upgrades in the
story and also had a hand on helping us
with our sparrows but where is she or
what about the speaker in destiny one
here was the main story teller who
loosely and yeah I mean very loosely
held the narratives together he's also
the block directly linked to the big
golf ball in the sky aka the traveler if
that sounded like complete gibberish
don't worry i'm working on breaking down
the entire story before September so we
can experience destiny two together and
saving the best until last we all know
the importance of beards they tell us
the difference between a man and a woman
they are the chin pubes that represent
manhood they had a think that is groaned
when a man goes bald beards are great
well in destiny one our characters were
not allowed facial hair but there are
signs in the trailer of stubble covered
gentlemen and even the artwork around
the game shows manly facial hair I can't
wait to give my character the beard she
deserves
damn sexy about seven things that got me
thinking after watching the destiny 2
trailer and we didn't even talk about
the lack of ghosts the weapons and the
potential faction quest after seeing
kadian action i'll definitely be
sticking with my hunter class in destiny
too but what about you please let me
know i'm adam from playstation grenade
like and subscribe for more destiny to
content Gary or kill Glenn is it I don't
know something with a G go